OUAI: GOUAI
AL MRN
EDORNEOR
NTEWNG
LA FFUS E
OUCEWAHEE
- O
AC TJI WS
A IS
RNEMCY.MONF
K SODTO
GU.
LO L TMSVE
SACE
R
WATE.E C B
ETE SHNDN
LL T Y
RANTNA T U T
OV W A T.
TES THE GYK
ME H RHT
IO
A NDUGO
Y,G.VEEM
K
>>EM W WO
WL-T W CS T
K .
5T,
HUBEGS PT.
HETURTHAL
'S EME
.
SAWH M W I A?
OR TN,OPEAD
D
A
JLE U
MY.
UYTU'TAP
EARIG
PEN  FEF AR
ITASRSEE M
EA.
LN,RENG
I
I 'TNE
SOEO W D KIM
CCSFTTO
IELLUNTHLD
W
MES GREA
ILD MON
ATYRE
E OU.TNSA
D? WO T,
EAI
FAOIOMNE A
ILSHIWA F
NOE TS IIS
OF OEF A N
E
RKNDTAI
THIO A I
ERTROME
I DHI AOI
SOES
UT N AGI T
LL UAKEYFF
T .
FI WHOOHNA INKHE
A,YNGOU
ITE I
,LLNT "AGY.
H
DNOY,SEC
ANROS HASNT
.E
THGER HHS
SRSTH
ANTSERIN
AD
RE S ICYOPRO
LIARNSFI
RV
USN THHA.
HE M L IUN
>>ATSS
E
IY TUG KMA
AP DT
ND H WAY
COVALHE
RSI
L--HE PEF
-HOLE
G E.
S I O TIN
BUM AINNY AGY
INNAT
STI'EDE T
ON K PE U
AUR]RELI
G R